we shouldn't have soda scorpion here on  The Price is Right meeting drew Carey a  childhood idol of mine friend for a very  long time shortly and I'm nervous before  I was born my older brother was in her  tummy she was praying over them and she  came to the price is right they wanted  to Cadillac and then money to buy a  house and that's when I came into the  picture two kids in a house in Newberry  Park California thank you very much Bob  Barr bastard yeah you know my my heart  is pumping and thumping with great  anxiety crap games $950 usually george  finishes the prize before you did uh  yeah we've got some people that are  really good at you know prices and  prices like that yeah games pro  tournament series 200 with aluminum  alloy legs push-button retractable net  and dual folding capabilities for easy  storage nine hundred and fifty dollars  we've never had anybody take over like  that you know totally change the rules  of our game  no on CBS secure keep a track at home